[Music]
you know they say the best things in
life are free like headshots I'm calling
for the score eSports and this week on
best of we're pinching our pennies and
taking a look at the best eco rounds and
force buys in csgo I mean you know how
it is you spend all that cash on an OP
no Armour get your [ __ ] rekt and now
your team is dirt poor but have no fear
because even on default pistols magic
can happen just ask the players in our
first section and just to be clear here
guys when we say default pistols I'm
talking about rounds where the majority
of the team is on us peas or Glocks p250
see Zed here and there it doesn't bother
me
goes out to the open does get the full
kill just yet reap X forget it now five
bullets left he'll go for a reload here
sunny is pushing for buddy will they hit
that bullet so it's a big upset Brad
from mousesports the con plant coming in
now or fly round tsunami can do an IP in
terms of buying but they're still
finding decent damage for getting that
shot enough zip it's they've actually
gotten closer in this round than they
were in the pistol exists it's gonna
follow it up flash down to Kerrigan he's
vulnerable and cajun beasts gone what is
going on a stroll is just falling apart
they're already on top of this defuse no
one will to get just yet the owner of
the kit but they're gonna force stuff to
carry it 14 HP at the face to get three
and they've done it and IP with no buy
pull out around what is that round 1 PC
54 your SP and somehow they're coming
out on top like four players alive
[Music]
so I deal with antennas and pressure
piggyback elbows bro
they're coming back it's charged with a
triple deal for simple p250 complaining
but everybody else's us tears no no one
here has Kevlar I declare bankruptcy
what are you doing go TV don't do this
to me now flaming me my honor flag right
here he's gonna line up two players
takes down there but is able to finish
the job on punchy 2 HP the C's is also
alive and kicking on a backstab they've
swapped places the t's have control of
the a site and lots of damage being done
flame is gonna take him down no way
there is no way they're gonna be able to
get a Nico oh my god hot G or 2 HP ace
crunch but a single bullet does it flame
using a k C's for the u.s. man I don't
believe it
[Music]
[Music]
while there's lemon to lift me up but
would you buy it
lots of fantastic results are able to
get into this into this bomb site start
to put these pistols to work on close
trade I'll be you that's the Big Shot to
miss it he's gonna miss it the second
time around as well that's a disaster
now pop fanatic they've lost La Roche
nobody's gonna fall exist he forces the
issue down into CT and now suddenly cold
and he's arrived at the scene he's gonna
try and get this back under control this
can very quickly go so so wrong a fourth
fanatic this is around the face had
almost read off at the beginning off the
timer gone on that bomb flusher down its
CT and you can see cold and leading the
charge it from the habit screams to be
able to get one flush up he falls what
is going on Jordan won't be one of those
for the phase again though this is one
that I was just gonna have to go through
there shouldn't be too much done from
them feet they have zero almost they
have one p250 that's it so rest of them
now from G to taking her time very
spread out but all of my sister finds
his first mark on the screen
unfortunately it's a bit over aggressive
trying and retrieve that gun I don't
know luck towards the side of g2 or just
a read but watch your being so far
seeing nothing this is quite curious
that they've gone for this sort of play
in fnatic hat players here but no one
now left the challenge CW gonna be
trying to come back around Russia's got
a good spot to body already watching it
these are G's you are very aware in this
round they shouldn't start losing things
found a rifle do not lose and fnatic
you're knocking at the door of a victory
now shocks in our PK again will be asked
the same question
okay well that's a great start they take
down the V play oh oh no daddy there's
no way we just come on you know that's
actually insane dude it seems like it's
strong in the pistol at least one zero
phase two bomb planted and look at this
more mind games coming in Estrada's go
480 grains they're gonna need the window
I think another use of smoke nade the
window and it could be two kills I'm out
there [ __ ] this could actually be a
nightmare here they come the ass both
killed landing oh my goodness so not all
eco rounds are a complete wash sometimes
you got a little bit of cash and it's
burning a hole in your pocket and before
your teammates can type save you blown
your wad on that sweet sweet scout don't
tell me how to spend my money I mean you
gotta spend money to make money right
out toward mid far back on the truck
nobody's gonna pqz especially when
everybody's got C's 5 7
Molotov Zin set peace out shroud has let
them all pass one
oh great
Odin's Raven as everyone is gonna be
holding close they sprint their way into
a man who everyone is one they have no
idea what's occurring but they have been
bicycles as they all go tumbling down
it's just on sick you know one before
[Music]
and they're gonna run to the exact
strategy
I ain't broke don't fix it button yeah
now you've got an automatic pistol above
you and now in your lap he picks up a
goalie see y4k looking for the ace
he's spamming through reinforcements
have arrived it is gum p1v many it's
only an mv7 almost on svy so we've got
action here Junior has killed a man and
those maids have put in some work but
again this is Annie Quran from Penta
sports so it should that look good for
Vega but they've lost the bomb now
crystals are my god for what he didn't
get the kills but not like this not like
this not like this and I'd like this
[Music]
what what
okay so twitch just give this triple
kill so all of a sudden the round is
actually possible for liquid to win it
of nowhere Oscars alone and he gets
completely overwhelmed so twin sort of
absolutely nowhere clutches out that
round for Team Liquid and he's got the
time that it fuses bomb as well so there
you have it for the entries in
particularly swamp enough Cygnus phalanx
was gonna force our sea jet down the
throats of NBS keep pulling until the
magazine depth TVs for themselves
not like this again side by the TTS yell
on the hike on there oh dear what what
three kills for that stops very
intelligently him also spot over playing
their hand
another one from Phelps looking for the
pistol a so and he gets it as well to
every still quite strong Smiths what's a
very passive banking here just to get
shots uncontested pistols have now gone
the way of SK dragon count as well -
diesel shot to the round five versus
before and I be in tracking it's a go
the other side of the flowers good shot
likely for SK players as well and he's
ready assuming sole my goodness forest
this is unbelievable the shots he's
heading right now he's just toying with
them looking for more long and finally
take him down into three buses to colder
and taco after tried salvage the round
as they make their way toward the a size
taco looking for the blacks but no
matter the bomb goes down 25 seconds
power then I be done this the shots
worth just stellar
and now colder I don't think he has a
chance in this one you won't even have
time to get the bomb down here and I see
this bookie with a final Frank it's
Forest it's get right it's dragon it's
free realistic problems for both team
surfer close in a distance it's gonna
get one tap from a leisure looking for
more kills but simples got down as well
it is an eco for liquid three men still
live here so perhaps they can get the
mat turn that first lost a bit later on
so the leash is still water line
connects are more things from him but
he's gonna get taken down by up an extra
two
with blaze remaining hiko's taken down
to though so fallen and cold at last man
standing
the bomb is coming up the slope and we
have to range on the eco doesn't have
any weapons yet so he kids gonna have to
fill out a massive clutch in order to
keep this for esteem bullets got no
cover and he's gonna go down straight
away that's coldzera he hasn't looking
arrange them at tempo this could really
go either way I'm a penetration 40 to 50
foot mp7 the floor in something from
Miko is he actually gonna do this cause
it's got less than 1080p this eliminates
go time who's going to do it the liquid
back in the game
lots of spring there with those a1
essence or 'this is a man rich now
spraying against is a almost finds what
a lesion fugly are very low to play none
of these tears to be seen where the nays
end there aren't any responses listed in
evident bunny or they've already use
them there's one ball top going it now
that the kills start to trickling forest
fossils in the CT side it will once
again jumpy hiko about to pull up we go
we've got three from behind quad can he
find a fourth he gets the fourth he's
odd for the answer it cats
3 4 CT left and this a Depot keep it
here because they from Big Mama I think
of putting in 1000 one versus one is it
realize there's a reason is pulled the
best player in the world and I quickly
witness together just believe in the
tech - just believe in the tech nice
anything is possible when you go taxi
taco with the D hoping he's gonna come
down to the timing as if has nothing a
doubt and first device rather he had the
edgy flash it's gone out and it was
actually fairly effective but Colton
sock are already wrapping around will
see they're gonna run right into him and
then cold overseas head up close will do
tremendous damage zip next he's got the
angle but he'll follow the taco next and
one kill at a time I stay gaming they're
working their way onto the site missing
all the shots here clave at least gets
one gonna be flashed in to try and stop
the bomb but he's too late in that as
well
finally Dupree comes in from banana
taking down car and now it's a 2-1 to
dissuades and close for strong as
they've given up a big lead already the
taco wins this first fight
south 9% it's gonna snap y'all like God
called Sara slicing up some Danish pork
right there okay Abel gets down rotation
is he gonna be another eco win no surely
not snacks he's gonna take sees the one
man who could have made a difference but
it's not gonna work out VP pickle around
a full eco for them okay so just them
now on the back foot on the eco sending
three players down long you'll see how
they choose to use these numbers bearing
in mind I have pistols and not much else
don't look anyone big swords long any
time soon device trying to hold things
over the piece of 52 Slayers heavily
tactical fanatic define sprint up the
angles and phi2 use the shutter to find
a third practice absolutely insane
he's only got several HP Khan do another
six I'm pro next he finds himself
against three players one close to the
thought he might not realize how close
see if he can even plant up on going for
the fake tryna find out where these
players are and he is gonna be unable to
do anything the whole lot of pistols
Kris Jo we had such potential but our PK
pocket 600 in the seconds gonna happen
to Dennis as well
mouses vines gonna be torn away from
them very very oh my god shock them and
justify one more the money isn't gonna
touch him and what on earth has just
happened this deagle is on fire shopkins
with well Nico is on fire 5 he recovers
the AEK as well once - great work during
the pcapp can he get the glass he should
not be able to do this - wrenegade
getting slaughtered let's fall for April
this big market oh my god he gets to aim
with a baby whoo no Armour about ready
to lose the ball top here as well with
my kiss falling down options are the
players for Penta just tossing left now
as the peek over the flame front - Nico
Hughes had a good chance he finally
takes the killer stick Oh must've been
reloading or something similar then I
able to find the shot the TAS did a heck
of a lot on these plate whole races
around to the he falls backwards over
the double stack here into fights into
the deep okay then somewhere
[Music]
pass the ball pump in hand will be using
from the bomb plot know if I'm gonna go
down so this box is gonna gain something
just won't be main but this is maybe
less than optimal angle to push from
throw their ball is the call of a pantry
knows how to make the plays at this
point a place for the training of the
kill who goes against him not even be a
factor exciplex drops this debris this
is give it away
I'm gonna rotate in a second maybe he's
got it shot as well it still had my
vision to win the exchange and around I
would say it's going to follow in my
fashion is SK control today or do they
all my goodness automatic for HP these
two kills do is actually going on
undetected they went to watch a big ball
automatic another and they win the round
that you have to be kidding me that is
the most insane round a deagle has had
yet in this tournament damage with the
th but the Zeus out instead and looking
to get a little bit closer and there it
is mix well gone
they picked up and get one more chance
can't even comes right into a Tareq with
a huge double kill one with the Taser
and now it's canoodle on the other side
see set 75 in Andy's gonna take down NBA
looking for more yola's gets a double in
a full round cloud line turning it
that's unbelievable
[Music]
perhaps law to it only for a second
though the still trying to check things
out meanwhile scoodle continues to get a
couple kills here next getting that
closer position and the t's kind of
swarm the area here skadoodle with
another one single-handedly keeping
cloud nine this round right now it's two
people in the smoke is that right and
big can't seem to find a way to win this
here as we see with a knife just like
that one away from match point on the
eco they were only planning to get the
bomb down never find 20 bucks in your
coat pocket I'm talking about this feels
good right well not as good as finding
an ak-47 on the ground when you've
invested little to nothing in the round
[Applause]
but again not much to really be done
here and it seems that g2 are about to
take the bball fight very quickly it'd
be its creeps waiting for somebody to
speak it connects over extensor
slowly people started streaming down at
some point
say [ __ ] to come in and indeed that
positioning has paid off for the
seconds out forget it hit the last man
standing here jumping p3t quite a feat
must be done
[Music]
if we could get so he killed after
bombers walk and now he's opposition
here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
seldom see them and not when they matter
as well I'd really really like to see
MIP change the pace on the upcoming
around obviously this round it doesn't
make that big of a difference although
they aren't gonna go for the for the
smoke into spawn and then try and see if
they can rusty might actually be really
powerful here all of meister can't see a
thing for the smoke there's five people
coming Crim's with the a cake and a
pickup the first one for us goes down
frames this gonna fall to Freiburg and
Freiburg with the second kill that is a
big trouble you down as well and he'll
look at it ni p a man up they have the
fog inside the site they're trying to
get into positions and flush a very
nearly caught them doing that I could
have been dangerous all of my stuff
takes down Freiburg goes for a second
one but I was there to drop all our
points then our 2v3 this is an eco round
turn into a big advantage fantastic
they're gonna have to coordinate this
really well to get into the site and a
loo this is a big off angle as well it's
it's gonna pick up pronet and flush
that's not a lot he could do right now
you might have to just walk away and
leave it at this one v3 and n IP are
they even gonna let him escape get right
goes down and flush us out of time as
well that's such a big victory for an IP
[Music]
good find from them so far spam through
the smoke who were trying to distract a
little bit because relics is actually
sitting inside of the smoke he's gonna
pounce now he's gonna come around the
side he actually finds one can he get a
second one he's got an eight-game is a
beep everybody gets a third wanna play
from relics and he can afford he's gonna
go for the reload and taps the bomb
trying to pull him up he gets the fourth
one as well Last Man Standing is gonna
be rogue to cover up with what's that
intro oh my god republic the ace on a
USB safe one of me
well guys that's all we got for you on
best of this week now I'm not gonna lie
to you my whole life is like an eco
round if you have or spy at best so go
ahead hit that like button and sub to
the channel and put your boy Colin on
that full bye thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]